[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always Alex mullering and I'm excited to
be talking with you about our theme
tonight we're talking about trading and
Counting and exchanges so when I talk
about a trade what I specifically mean
is essentially an equivalent exchange so
not just a capture right so something
like this let's say I capture this Pawn
on V5 and my opponent plays an extra
Pawn here well now if I capture this
I've already captured one Pawn
if I take a second one I mean they can
take back maybe this is a Gambit of some
kind but they've given up some material
um in some cases it would just be
totally free where I'm not going to be
talking really about that obviously if
you can win material that's great
um and we might look at some puzzles
where that is a factor but really we're
going to be focusing on stuff like this
right this type of position where if I
take you have the option to recapture
and
so it would be an equal exchange we
might trade a pair of knights we might
trade a knight for a bishop maybe a
bishop for a rook or two Rooks for a
queen and the question is when we are in
a situation in a game when we are
looking when we have the opportunity to
make a trade or could create the
opportunity for a trade
how do we know whether or not to do it
a lot of things factor into this you
know the material count how much space
you have uh some of it can be like if
one player is more on the attacking side
and one is on the defense so there's a
lot of factors that go into this and
we're going to kind of go uh one at a
time but in order to really evaluate you
know when we should make a trade it's
fundamental to understand how do we even
count the material and know what is
equal
okay so the first thing is I want to
take a look at this position
I actually use this example and I think
my very first beginner breakdown so this
is a blast from the past you may have
seen it before I believe that episode is
called surveying the scene so as always
you're free to go watch it it's going to
cover some of the same ideas but it's
more just about evaluating a position in
general this is going to be more about
counting material and making exchanges
but in this position it's Black's turn
to move and there's a lot to think about
but if you had black in this position I
think the obvious question or I mean the
obvious thing going on in this position
is that there's a lot of tension and
pressure right our Rooks our Knight our
Bishop are all attacking whites Knight
here it's defended by a bunch of things
so we at least have the option to make
the exchange in some fashion or other
so the first question when I see a
position like this is okay we have a
capture on the board
should we make the exchange or not
maybe even prior to that we would look
and say if I do this am I going to win
material so the first stage when we say
counting in looking at an exchange is
trying to identify
how many attackers there are and how
many Defenders there are so with black
to move
if we were to initiate some Exchange
we would we have a knight that's
attacking a bishop that's attacking a
rook and then this Rook behind it once
this Rook takes then our second Rook
would be able to recapture as well so we
have four pieces that are part of the
attack
how many does white have on the defense
so one they have this bishop they have
both of their Rooks so that's uh two and
three and they also have their King
so this is a four versus four kind of uh
Exchange
and any time it's the same amount of
attackers as Defenders then the defender
is going to be the last one to capture
because the attacker is the first one to
take the piece so we'll use our number
one and they'll use their number one two
and two three and three four and four
and in the end they will be the last
ones who make a capture okay so we at
least know that the same amount of
things are going to make a capture in
this case if we had an extra one then we
might just be winning just because we
have too many attackers they don't have
enough Defenders but now that we know
they're at least adequate on their
defenses obviously if they've if they
have equal or more then they're going to
be fine in terms of that we also want to
look at the Quality or the value of
these pieces
and perhaps the order right in this
position if we decide to make an
exchange we wouldn't want to start with
the Rook most likely because then we're
going to have a rook traded for this
Knight and perhaps white doesn't have to
trade all the way down maybe they can
you know have more value you know losing
just the night and getting The Rook
um now someone in the chat has suggested
a nice looking move Knight to C4
which is not an exchange this is the
idea I believe you're looking for is we
are attacking this rook and because it
is fully encapsulated on all sides it
cannot move so this would actually
effectively trap The Rook unfortunately
in this position Knight to C4 is
actually a mistake uh does anyone in the
chat or in the audience know why what is
wrong with Knight to C4 how could white
respond and get us into a lot of trouble
believe see
right yeah exactly
um so Knight to C5
the problem is our move attacks this
Rook which is fairly forcing right we
have lots of videos on forcing moves at
this point please check those out
um if you aren't really sure what that
means uh so we are making a threat but
white can actually make an even more
forcing move a check
it not only moves the night out of the
way to open up the Rook it also Forks
our King and rook and now we're actually
going to be losing material if we look
at the count right we're going to have
to move our King somewhere we can't take
the Knight with anything and you can't
block a knight because it jumps so after
we move the king probably to F7
in order to defend our Bishop
white has one two three pieces attacking
a rook and we only have one Defender
which means again using our counting
they're going to win some material here
and this Rook is actually going to get
out of the way so we don't even get to
take that
so uh we do want to be very careful one
of the benefits to making an exchange is
it is going to simplify the position
white is not going to have the option to
look for any fancy tactics in this case
they actually wouldn't be able to
because we just get rid of that night so
the night that used to Fork us is no
longer on the board but also in general
simplifying can be helpful in certain
circumstances we'll talk about that more
here and actually in this position it's
probably the best move
uh maybe we lead with the bishop just
because it's also a check so maybe a
little more forcing but we will want to
trade all the way down
because even though the material
exchange was equivalent if we look at
the resulting position you'll notice
that we can count up what's left we have
one two three or sorry white has four
pawns and we have one two three four
five six pawns we are two pawns ahead
um our King is slightly more centralized
than our opponents and we can kind of
pick and choose one of the sides to go
to and clear out and most likely we'll
be able to make a queen before our
opponent and win the game because of
that
so we can actually see that all the way
back in this position before we make any
of the exchanges app we can count up and
see oh it's going to be all equal in the
end but we also want to count the
overall material right so these pawns
these Knights and Bishops and Rooks and
everything and we can see that black is
up these two pawns which means we're
going to want to simplify
okay so
um
this is kind of just an introduction of
the some of the things we're going to
want to look at when we are deciding
whether or not to make an exchange but
now let's go into the more kind of basic
idea of the material point value for
each of these if you're not familiar we
have a kind of General system of how
many points is each thing worth
chess is not a game about points right
it's again about Checkmate if this if I
have given up all of my pieces and can
still Checkmate your king it doesn't
make a difference what I have or what
you have in that case the game is over
but most of the time games are going to
come down to trading off a bunch of
pieces and going into an end game where
one side has slightly more material and
is able to win the game with that extra
material
and so we have a point system that helps
us have a general sense of how much
value we should give to each piece or
Pawn the pawns we generally say are
worth one point a piece
the knights and Bishops we say are about
three points each Rooks we say are about
Five Points each and queens we say are
about nine and the points are again
relative to the value of the piece and
the value of the piece is relative to
the power it exerts on the board
so consider a pawn right it's only able
to move forward it can only Attack One
space forward on diagonals so it's
limited in both its movement and its
attacking potential pawns obviously have
enormous value near the end of the game
when they can get to the end of the
boarding promote so it does change over
time and we'll talk about that but at
least at the initial position and for
most of the chess game the pawns are
going to be the lowliest things you are
not so worried about losing them or
trading them off
Knights and Bishops are next they uh
Knights are more limited in their
movement right they can't go all the way
across a board in any straight line like
the other pieces but their unique
ability to jump over pieces and move in
a pattern that no other piece can really
catch like allows them some tricky
opportunities right you can get Forks
against pieces that normally like the
queen but normally you couldn't attack
like that purely because the Knight
moves different than anything else so
that makes it also worth three points
the bishop sees all the way across the
board on the diagonals three points The
Rook up and down all the way across the
board Five Points and then the queen is
as if you put the rook and Bishop
together right all the way across the
board up down side to side on the
diagonals she's worth nine points so the
most valuable piece Save the King which
we don't give any point value to because
it's never going to be considered for an
exchange if you lose the king you lose
the game it's Checkmate so there's no
reason to give the point value the only
reason we use points is to help us in
these decisions about making trades or
captures
okay so a question though given some of
that how come I'm sorry I'm kind of
jumping ahead a little bit how come the
bishop is only worth
three points while The Rook is worth
five right if we jump to some kind of
just position here this is not a good
opening it's just to give the example
notice that they control when they're
kind of centrally located relatively the
same number of squares they both attack
all the way across the board in a
straight line just one of them is on the
diagonal one of them is on the verticals
and horizontals so how come the bishop
is only worth three when The Rook is
worth five why does The Rook get that
extra bump
anyone have an idea
why would we value our Rooks slightly
more than our Bishops
even though they both seem to move in
the same kind of way
you know
so the rookkin castle that's true the
bishop doesn't have any special ability
like that
um so perhaps that gives it a slight
marginal bump but I would say even in
like an end game after castling has been
done still The Rook is worth more than
the bishop
um Bishop has limited movement on
certain squares uh yeah so that's much
closer to the idea
um and Shane Briggs kind of bringing us
full circle with the comment uh the
bishop is actually limited to its
starting color so in this starting
position notice how we have a bishop on
these lighter squares and a bishop on
these darker squares
we actually usually refer to them as the
light and dark sword Bishop because no
matter how many moves I get I could get
infinite moves in a row but my Bishop
can never change colors so if you are
able to put your pieces on the opposite
color of my Bishop I'm going to be in
trouble whereas a rook
can change colors it can hit something
on every possible Square so even though
in one turn their movement is relatively
equal
in the long run you can kind of play
against a bishop in a way that you can't
really play against a rook
okay
to kind of illustrate that
if we look at this bishop or this
example of an end game the material is
equal right both sides have the same
number of Pawns the only difference is
one side it's a bishop and one side has
a knight but notice how here black with
a light squared Bishop is actually
missing basically all of White's pieces
the only piece white has on the board on
a light square is this Pawn which could
easily be pushed up one it's just not in
any danger at the moment white has
maneuvered most of their pawns their
King and their Knight all to be on a
square that the bishop can't Target if
it was a rook this would not be nearly
as effective but because it's a bishop
there's just nothing you can do so this
is why the bishop is only worth three
points versus the The Rook a rook is
slightly better for that reason
we also want to think about again all of
this the point I'm giving you the reason
we're talking about this material and
this is a pretty basic fundamental
concept is what the material is worth
is all about how can we understand this
in the context of when should we make a
trade
so consider this position
let's say it's white to move and we're
looking at the board here which side do
you like better and why
if you had to play a side here if you
had to pick sit down at this board and
you got to choose whether you're going
to play the white pieces or the black
pieces which one do you think you'd have
an easier time with
foreign
okay so yeah uh Rob USCF in the chat not
sure if I'm pronouncing that right uh
wants to play White um a few other
people saying that as well King safety
is part of it although with Kings off
the board or sorry with Kings off the
board with Queens off the board if you
have Kings off the board you're playing
a totally different game but with Queens
off the board uh King safety is not it's
still important but it's not as critical
it's a lot harder to attack the king
without such a heavy piece like the
queen
um but actually look at these Bishops
look at how many squares they are
controlling and putting pressure on this
dark squared Bishop is pinning this
Knight to this Rook this one is keeping
this Knight in place where we'll take
this pawn and then attack this Rook
um but they are just dominating the
center uh and they're kind of dominating
these Knights
right the knights are not able to jump
as far this is what we would call an
open position which is specifically when
the the Pawns in the center of two files
so the D and E pawns for both sides are
gone they've been traded or taken and so
because it's much more open the bishops
get a huge bump in power and in this
case the question would then be so not
only do we want to play as white if
you're playing as white do you want to
exchange your Bishops for these Knights
maybe in some limited circumstances like
maybe you can make an argument we'll
take this one and double these pawns and
create a weakness but generally
um we would much rather have the Bishops
because they can control more squares
and control is what gives something
value
um contrast that with this position
in this position it's black to move and
Black's Queen is in danger so I'll just
move their Queen out of the way but
without that being a factor in the
position
uh in this case black is actually a head
material white only has four five six
pawns whereas black has one two three
four five six seven so black is up a
pawn it's a bishop for Knight Queen for
Queen two Rooks two Rooks
um but in this case I suspect most
people would still say they want to play
as white even though we're down a pawn
if we really stop and take a look this
bishop is pretty atrocious we can move
this way and control some of these
squares but
um contrast that with what this Knight
is capable of there's Fork potential on
really all of these squares like black
would love to play very soon Rook to C1
but or sorry to C8 but then they have to
worry about potentially us getting in
Knight to E7 maybe if we can move this
queen around
um and this Bishop's going to have to
stay and guard all of these squares
and yeah this this Knight is in this
essentially if you were black here and
you had the option to take off your
bishop and take off this Knight you
would do it in a heartbeat because this
Knight is going to cause you so many
problems that this bishop isn't equipped
to deal with
um so that's one consideration right is
how are these pieces going to be able to
be used effectively in this position
even when they're equal right a knight
and a bishop we both say are generally
worth three points but
um in some positions we're going to
favor one versus the other and that
should inform your decision to make a
trade
uh okay something else that I mentioned
in passing earlier is the idea of kind
of Pawns how they get more value so in
this position black is up a bishop
versus a pawn so this is a three-point
piece versus a one point Pawn
but in this position it's actually
basically a draw because the Rooks are
equal the three pawns over here versus
these three pawns is about equal and
with white to move White's going to play
this move Pawn to B7
this Pawn is no longer worth one point
right thinking about it that way is not
really helpful because this Pawn may
only have the ability to move forward
one square and attack two but
effectively you should treat this Pawn
as a potential Queen
um so
assigning it at exact point value is
kind of difficult but at the very least
black the question you have to ask in
this position is if black does not take
this Pawn can they stop the queen from
promoting no and they need to stop like
the back rank so maybe if they play
something like H6 and allow a queen
obviously we can see that this queen is
worth more than this bishop which means
that in this position Black's best move
is going to be to give up their Bishop
for that pawn
and make sure the material or the
position is equal
where now both sides have the same
material there's not really A major
advantage or disadvantage for either
player this is probably a draw but black
is very happy to make that exchange of
Bishop for Pawn even though the point
value system might disagree with in
general so we have to be thinking about
kind of the Pawn's upward Mobility as it
happens and factoring that into our
decision to exchange right this would be
I would say this is pretty this is not
only an equal exchange for black this is
actually Black's probably trading up
because they are they are much happier
to get rid of this bishop and stop this
Pawn from promoting
uh something else to consider is uh the
bishop pair so a pair of Bishops we
generally think of as being worth
slightly more than a knight and a bishop
or even two knights because again think
about the way the bishop controls a
color complex
it's going to hit all of these light
squares here but imagine we place a
second one maybe right next to it and
the amount of squares that these two
pieces control together is pretty
ridiculous
um so let's take a look at this position
this position actually comes from a game
uh from a few years ago between Alpha
zero and stockfish it was when they were
testing out kind of the alpha zero I
think the Google deepmind AI
um to try and like get a sense of how it
could teach itself to play chess
um and you know the technology is maybe
a little bit outdated AI has become more
of a Resurgence recently but I think
this position really shows something
quite remarkable in this position it's
black to move
and uh let's first take a quick count of
the material so white has three pawns
black has four five six pawns so black
has three extra pawns they both have two
Rooks they uh both have well white has
the bishop pair versus a bishop and
Knight so technically three and three
again the bishop pair is a little more
valuable but we'll get into that
uh and then Queens so in this position
um black is effectively up three points
they're basically up a full piece and
yet blacks almost lost for sure here in
the game what happened is they played
Knight to D7 which does reveal an attack
on the queen but also attacks Our Queen
something we're going to talk about very
quickly is
when you are uh ahead or behind and
actually I can just talk about it now
one of the most important factors when
it comes to whether or not you want to
make a trade is whether you are ahead in
material or behind in material for the
side that is ahead in material so in
this case black making trades is almost
always going to help you because you
want to work towards simplifying the
position into a winning end game right
think about that first example we saw
I'm going to jump back to it really
quick
in this position it's complex there's a
lot of chances for mistakes
but if we can simplify and trade
everything down
this is a way easier game to win for
black where we just have two extra pawns
than this position
and so in for the same reason
when we jump to this position
um
black would be more than happy to trade
Queens
because they're up material and if they
can kind of press this advantage
and trade off all the dangerous pieces
to their position they're going to end
up with a few pieces or Pawns in the end
that white just doesn't have and they're
going to be winning so obviously
stockfish is not once or sorry Alpha
zero in this case is white does not want
to go for this and Retreats the queen
okay now the Queen's in danger and
there's not really a lot of good options
for it and so stockfish ended up playing
the move Rook to F6 and what's amazing
in this position
is even though we can take the Rook for
the bishop right Five Points versus
three in this position Alpha zero
evaluated that the Bishops the bishop
pair because of how much control and
pressure it's exerting on Black's
position they actually chose not to take
the Rook they thought this bishop is
much more valuable having this pair of
Bishops together is way more valuable
than just cashing in for the quick
material grab so they pushed the pawn to
F4 black got out of the pin with Queen
to E7 and now okay the rook's not pinned
so now the Rook is going to move if you
don't take it and amazingly alphazier
decided yes I want to take the Rook but
not with the bishop with the Rook
Alpha zero again thinks this bishop pair
is just such a massive Advantage it
controls so much space in the enemy
territory
um that it would rather make an equal
exchange of material in a position where
it's worse in order to keep this pair of
Bishops
black responded I won't go through this
whole game but black played Knight to F6
white pushed the pawn again just trying
to break through
Queen to E3 and now Alpha zero sees a
way that it can simplify into a winning
end game it takes this Pawn allowing for
a trade of Queens normally you wouldn't
want to allow a queen trade when you are
ahead in material or sorry when you're
behind a material in this case it's
going to work out well because of a nice
tactical idea instead of recapturing the
queen first we play Pawn takes Pawn
checking the king
the king moves out of the way
Rook takes Queen
and in this position again the pawn is
too valuable it's going to become a
queen very soon if we're not careful and
so stockfish takes the pawn and loses
the Knight and in this position now it's
the alpha zero is the one with the
advantage it's two pawns versus four but
two of them are doubled
we have the bishop pair against a bishop
that is effectively just a tall Pawn and
then Rooks are equal so Alpha zero went
on to kind of demolish stockfish in this
game it's a really beautiful game
um but the the point I really wanted to
emphasize here is uh the simple point is
that the pair of Bishops is really
really strong if you can use it in the
right way to control space again notice
this is a much more open position
there's one Pawn here in the center on
D5 but most of the central pawns are out
of the way and even this Pawn on D5 is
not in the way of these Bishops so
they're just kind of eyeing down laser
focused on Black's King
uh so that's kind of the short-term
point but the long-term point is with
all of this right some of this might
seem really basic and fundamental but
understanding the value of our material
whether you express it in the point
system or whether you uh are looking
more at the position itself and seeing
okay I recognize that The Rook is worth
five points and the bishop is worth
three points but I would rather keep
this piece because it's doing much more
for my team and then again to make the
same decision here this work is not
doing nearly as much as this bishop
so sometimes you will make these
considerations and that will affect how
you make trades
and also how you just count material in
general
okay another major consideration
uh yeah no humans are never going to
stand a chance against bots this is true
um but okay another consideration when
evaluating trades and deciding whether
or not we want to make an exchange has
to do with space
and I don't mean space the final
frontier I mean space on the board
um
notice in this position
that white has a lot more space than
black white has effectively controlled
the center right these two Central pawns
are really dominant and black has a
strong Center as well right with this
Pawn chain but because all of Black's
pieces are really stuck behind their
pawns I mean you look at all of these
undeveloped pieces this Knight really
doesn't have anywhere good to go I mean
I guess it can go to B6 but it's not
really helping out the team over there
this bishop on H7 it's look it has a
long scope but it's not really targeting
anything at the moment
and look at all of this room that
White's pieces have right they can
basically all of this space over here on
the queen side a good amount of the
space on the queen side the reason my
space is important
is because when you control more of the
board and you have more space like in
this position you generally want to
avoid trades because your pieces have
more you know room to roam around and
find good squares to jump to whereas
when you're behind in space like black
is here if you can afford to make a
trade especially just of equal value not
even a sacrifice of an actual exchange
or a trade
um you're making room right right now uh
this bishop and this Knight might be
competing for the square E7 if I can
trade one of them off then now only one
of them has to worry about finding its
way to this square and I just have a
little bit more breathing room
so when you have more space you kind of
want to deny trades to your opponent in
this example black played the move
Knight to E7 white castled and black
played Knight to G6 right black is
looking to trade because these pieces
are in the way this Knight is now
competing with this bishop it's still
sort of competing for space with this
one you know if this bishop comes to E7
now this Knight's gonna have a harder
time finding a place to live
so white wood or sorry so black would
love to trade and actually trading here
is not White's worst option
um if we take
we can maybe start to expand with F4 and
it's still clear that white has an
advantage
um in especially in terms of the space
we're pressing to play F5 and try and
break open you know the center and
Black's Castle
but if white is a little bit more
patient and plays something like Knight
H5
these plans don't disappear we still
have the I we still have the space
advantage and the potential to push
forward and attack but now notice that
this Knight on H5 is actually doing a
lot one this Knight is now just in the
way it's not really helping because it's
not stopping F4 it's not I mean I guess
it could go to H4
I don't know that that's again really
doing much for for Blackheath and it's a
little exposed we can maybe just Retreat
the bishop and we're fine
um
but we're also with this 985 move tying
down another piece right Black's already
cramped for space and now if this bishop
moves we're going to take this Pawn with
check so Black's pieces are incredibly
restricted
the point here is when you have the
advantage in space generally you want to
avoid trades because your pieces are
going to be able to have more room to
move around the board make find critical
squares attack important weaknesses and
your opponent is going to have a harder
time maneuvering around each other their
pieces are going to bump into each other
okay let's talk about another
idea I mentioned in the beginning
offense and defense right whether you
are on the attack where you were on the
defense also radically impacts whether
or not you should trade
uh in this position
it is black to move I believe we called
check and white blocked with their Queen
offering a trade and let me put it to
you do you think as black we should make
this queen trade why or why not
foreign
no keep attacking the king so that's
really important yeah the king is
exposed White's King is weak this is
maybe the most central idea there's a
secondary one but the the critical idea
is this is a ridiculous position
um White's King is on C5 and we have
Queens on the board
um there's not shelter for this King
it's totally out in the open
um so yeah this is incredibly dangerous
for White's King if we trade Queens
there's two problems one we have
released so much of the pressure of our
attack it's a lot harder now to kind of
contain this King and punish it for
being out so early not only that but if
we actually just look at this if we look
at this full Exchange
white stressed up a piece
right white has this extra Knight we
have one two three four five versus one
two three four five pawns we both have
two Rooks and white has a knight now
White's not developed but their King is
more active which without Queens on the
board now matters a lot
um and we're not developed either so why
should stop a piece and we can actually
see that already in this in this
position right uh with that big trade
we're able to at least win this Pawn
back but yeah white tip a piece so we
don't want to trade for material anyway
but also even if material were equal we
would not want to trade in this position
because White's King is just so open
if you have ideas
what do you think uh given the whites
King is open let's see if we can find a
way to punish them for being out what is
a good attack we can do
to both the
okay so I think C takes D6 makes a lot
of sense to start with
notice that this King now is the only
piece defending this queen so we want to
force the king to move now if we take
obviously if they take back we'll just
take their Queen and win but what if
they go King to D5 because that's the
only other square right they can't go to
C4 our Bishop controls that so if we
take on D6 and they play King to D5
how can we continue our attack
uh we let's see I want to make sure I'm
not missing a comment here
she takes the queen A3 so we can't do
queen A3 they have that covered
we could Castle so we have to notice our
Queen is still hanging right we can't do
something too slow if we play C takes D
King D5 our Pawn is going to be on D6 so
we can't Castle we can't play Rook d8 um
because they're just gonna take our
Queen so we have to do something very
forcing
oh I think someone found it uh
okay so someone is suggesting after the
King goes to D5 we'll play Bishop to B7
check
okay so I like that
um that does give up the C4 Square so
now the king will be on C4
are so we take they play here Bishop
check King moves to C4
what can we do to kind of do the
finishing blow in this position to
punish White
again we're going to take their Pawn
we're going to check their King they're
going to go to
C4
yeah pumpkin the cat nice to see you
back it's been a little while glad to
have you in the chat Rook to C8 check
so first again notice here after we take
the only Square they can go to to
defense The Queen Is Here
Bishop check the only Square they can go
to that defends the queen is on C4 and
now Rook to C8 check and the King has
nowhere they can go our Queen covers
these squares our Bishop this one
every Square they could go to is taken
so their King will have to leave or
their Queen will have to step in front
but either way we will take the queen
and in short order win the game
so uh yeah
the bottom line is when you are again
when you are on offense generally
speaking you do not want to make trades
there are some exceptions if your
opponent has like one piece that's
holding everything together and you can
take it and the whole position crumbles
then yeah obviously there's going to be
exceptions to any rule I think that's
probably the only real principle I give
in chess if there's one absolute rule
it's that there's always an exception
which is a bit of a paradox don't think
about it too hard
um
but
when you are attacking trading pieces
just means your opponent has less to
deal with
um and it's easier for them to escape
your threats
and conversely when you're behind right
if you have a way to force this trade
that's going to be great
um and we're going to kind of talk about
that a little bit more here I want to
make one note
I've talked about this actually exact
position before not the starting
position that that's funny but I have
but actually if we play a few moves here
and let's just play some very common
developing moves nothing too unusual
this is something I see a lot
we want to attack this weak Square F7
right both sides one to point out that
the square is weak but the problem is
in this position let's make an
evaluation we could make an equal trade
we could take this Pawn twice
white will lose or sorry white will lose
a knight and a bishop black will lose a
rook in a pawn three and three is six
five and one is six so we could make
that exchange and it would be an equal
exchange the question is should we make
that trade as white why or why not
foreign
okay pumpkin the cat again with the
right idea yeah we're going to lose two
developed pieces not just that black has
three developed pieces so we're already
a little behind in development just
because we wasted a turn playing Knight
to G5 moving this piece twice
but also
after we make this exchange we're gonna
have exactly zero developed pieces if we
go through with this
then we have all of our pieces on the
back row the only thing we have
developed into the game is a Pawn on e4
whereas black has a knight oh two
knights and a bishop all in nice Central
positions
and some people will make the argument
yeah but look at this King it's so weak
okay that's fair you have exposed
Black's King but the problem is
we don't have enough material activity
right our pieces aren't in any position
to attack this exposed King if our
pieces were more active you know then
maybe we could make an argument that
making a equal exchange to lure out
their King in order to you know have
some big attack could be justified but
you want to think about what pieces
you're going to have left
again we are too overzealous here with
our attack trading a bunch of things and
we actually trade too much to make it
worthwhile
so in this case we wouldn't want to make
that trade
um okay
this is another type of kind of common
opening mistake I see from beginners
um
we're going to do the same kind of thing
right bring out our Knights bring out
our Bishops very common opening ideas
and in this position instead of playing
this what we did before of Knight to G5
on attacking the spawn we already know
that's not going to work
in this case the question is
should we play Bishop to G5
this looks like a very natural move
right we want to develop this bishop and
this seems like a very good Square for
it pinning the Knight to the queen
so should we play this move why or why
not
anyone in favor anyone against
this one is a little more subtle than
the previous example but still very
relevant
and if you don't play E4 I'm sorry I'm
using a lot of E4 examples
um we'll give some D4 love to people
next time
but yeah so what do we think
the idea I think is quite strong right
we want to play Bishop G5
because we're pinning this Knight and if
Black's not careful we might even be
able to play Knight to D5 attack the
pinned piece
really take control of the center it
seems really strong
but there is a subtle problem maybe a
few
the first thing is anytime you make this
pin
whether it's your white or black or
you're pitting a bishop or you're
pinning a knight with a bishop
what you want to think about is
if I'm forced away
do I Retreat or do I take
because in this position the benefit to
a pen is that we can maybe in the long
term put some pressure on it or we can
maybe exploit a piece that it should be
defending and isn't but they can
immediately deal with this by playing
the move H6 and now we have a real tough
question
if we trade
it's even for even
but do we want to be Trading
do we want to give up the bishop pair
for you know just a knight
so now let's take a look username 0416
has a great question what's the point of
H6 right we're just going to retreat so
yeah I agree we probably don't want to
take right I don't think this is going
to get us anywhere so we retreat
and now G5
notice that black has not committed to
kingside castling yet
this expansion is totally justified
they're pushing our Bishop back
if you want you can try and make some
crazy sacrifice
most of the time it's not going to be
worth it
um
so we're going to have to retreat if we
don't want to be down in material
already that's going to be a risky game
if we're not and just consider let's
contrast this now let's say black now
plays Bishop G4
well now with our Bishop on G3 if we try
the same thing uh oh our Bishop's in the
way we actually can't continue to expand
with space
um it is not going to be hard for black
to just move their Queen somewhere and
queen side castle and have their King
very safe with some nice expansion on
the king side their pieces are doing a
lot more now they're they're really
threatening to play Knight D4 this is a
genuine threat for uh for black here
our threats were too slow we didn't want
to trade the bishop for the night
because we don't want to give up a
bishop pair and help activate the queen
but we also don't want to get into this
position where our pieces were stuck
without the ability to expand
so yeah let's take a look at some
Alternatives here so let's say instead
of playing Bishop G5 we play H3 first
okay now black castles now I think
Bishop G5 is already a lot a better
option
all right there's a subtle Improvement
because we're not forced to trade if
they play H6 we can drop back and now if
they play G5 I think that is a
concession
because this Pawn was actively defending
this castled King and black can try and
play this way but it is inviting more
danger right you generally want your
king to have Pawns in front of it
keeping it safe and so after we Retreat
here
we're not in that much danger I mean
maybe there's some threats of trying to
fight forward but black really again
does not want to be making trades on the
side where their King is going to be
exposed it's probably going to be too
weakening
we haven't committed to castling yet so
we can still Castle Queen side as white
here and maybe start to try and break
through on our own
um so those are some of the things you
would want to consider with this early
Bishop G5 right it relates to counting
and trading because I think if you're
going to play this move you have to know
ahead of time if they just force you
away am I going to trade or not in some
cases it might be good maybe you have
maybe you're going to double their pawns
or find a tactical reason in your favor
or force them to try and expand too far
and undefend their King but if you don't
want to trade and you don't want to
retreat then you should not play this
move
okay
um so that's just kind of one minor note
but I do see it in a lot of opening
games
is there ever reason to play H6 to kick
the bishop away without G5 afterwards
sometimes
um like in this position even though we
can't
like black doesn't want to fully commit
to playing G5 H6 I think is still
reasonable here
um just because
we can't really deal with it either way
it's still going to be pinned but
sometimes it's nice to give our King an
escape square like this is the kind of
thing where okay now for the rest of the
game you don't have to worry as much
about a back rank Checkmate so there are
still advantages to it
um
but you you lose a big one right one of
the main reasons is because you can
expand forward
okay a few final points
let's
step back and really think what's the
whole point to these points to these
evaluations right well I want to really
break it down so you can always connect
to your ideas
uh at the bottom line the reason we want
to evaluate these material exchanges
whether or not we should make a trade or
not is how it factors into US winning
losing or drawing the game of chess
in this position it's white to move
black is better they're up a pawn it is
a doubled Pawn but they're up one
but because Rooks are still on the board
we can maybe fight for a draw we can
play some complicated moves and try and
make it as tricky as possible for black
in this position but there's one move
that looks so incredibly natural and
just loses almost on the spot
Black's King is more active in this
position as well that's a good point
pumpkin
Rook to E2 looks like a very natural
move just trying to call check this is a
like if you're low on time we're going
to call a Check figure out what to do
next this move is actually just dead
lost because now
black will play the move Rook E5
and black is going to do what they
wanted to do this whole time and
simplify so one of the final reasons to
consider equal exchanges right in this
position
black is not threatening to win material
right it's they're just offering a trade
we can take them they can take us it's
just an equal trade of pieces this is
not about winning material
but it is about saying an equal trade
when we get into an end game where we
can simplify if we take this Rook
then black can recapture with the king
or the pawn probably the pawn just to
undouble them this will create a past
pawn and we don't have any ways white to
stop this
black will very easily bring their King
out in front because their King is more
active
and help escort this Pawn all the way
home to become a queen and because we
don't have Rooks or minor pieces or
anything else on the board to complicate
that process this game is almost
certainly lost I would play anyone in
the world with this position as black
and
well some people will try and stalemate
me in tricky ways but at the very least
I could get a queen here against anyone
in the world
um
so you really want to consider
in these positions you know keeping
stuff complicated when you're the
defender when you are down in material
you don't want to trade because if your
opponent can simplify into a winning end
game just like our initial position in
the same way this one keeping the Rooks
on the board is just going to make it
that much harder okay yeah if Magus
wants to challenge me to that position
and just see if I can't get a queen I
would accept I'd be scared but I bet you
I could do it okay
but yeah and for those who don't see the
idea here sorry I should have clarified
the reason we have to make this trade
this is actually a great move from black
because it forces a trade if we move our
Rook anywhere else then there's a back
rank checkmate
so we can't move our work out of the way
and we can't move our King close enough
to defend it so any other move we just
lose our Rook
so that's the problem here black found a
way to force a trade of pieces so be
careful with your just willy-nilly
checks sometimes they can end up costing
big problems and end games like these
let's look at another kind of
simplification example here in this
position it's black to move
and
this might be a little counterintuitive
but I'm going to say okay so let's give
you the black pieces and see if you can
find what you think is the best move
here or at least one of the best moves
black has a few ways to win because we
have a queen on the board but what would
you do what is probably the simplest way
to win this game and as a note our pawns
are moving this way and White's Pawn is
moving this way
foreign so as black what should we do
so check there's a lot of reasonable
ideas for checks
um
actually I take that back there's two we
can check here and we can check here
anywhere else then we get taken
but we have some checks we can consider
but actually a few people in the chat
Rob USCF and uh sugar QBE
um not sure how you want that pronounced
but have both said the right idea is
actually in this position probably the
simplest way to win is to sacrifice the
queen for The Rook
this is no longer a Material Exchange
we're not winning material we're
actually actively giving up material but
for the purpose of simplification now
this is not a move I would recommend you
play unless you have spent enough time
to know how am I actually going to win
it right because there's still a little
bit of complexity here and if you're not
careful they're just going to win
so you have to be a little bit you know
planning ahead and make sure you know
that this is going to win
but yes and let's think about why if we
take this Rook okay they have to take
back
we can then take this Pawn so that's not
a threat anymore
and now we have two Pawns
that they have to stop with their King
and their bishop and the question is can
they
actually they can't
if we take
King takes Pawn there's really nothing
they can do if they try and bring their
King in
then we can start pushing this Pawn
if they try and reroute the bishop to
cover both
which they can effectively do
that's fine
but they're going to have to pick one
because whatever move they play our next
move we are playing either C1 queen or
H2 and they're gonna have to take it
and then we can move the other one so
for example say they play something like
this it really doesn't matter which one
you go for so let's just say we play H2
if they don't take it I'm making a queen
here so they have to take but then they
have given up defensive C1 and I make my
queen here and it should not be too hard
for me to find a way to Fork the king
and the bishop and win a clean end game
um you could also have played Queen here
and again they can no longer stop
promotion
so this is the type of example where if
you don't see for sure that you're
winning don't do it but it can be really
valuable especially if you study some
end games some King and pawn end games
and know which positions are going to be
winning for you and which aren't
um then being able to make those kinds
of Trades and simplify into a win is
really going to help you
and again in this position you probably
don't have to make that sacrifice to win
but it's going to give your opponent a
lot less chances to complicate the
position
if they have this Rook on the board so
username 0416 asking if Queen takes E6
is good I think it probably is fine the
danger is again we're still letting them
keep it complicated because now maybe
they don't trade Rooks
we're still probably able to win uh they
don't trade their work for the queen but
I if if I were playing with white here I
would Place some move that doesn't
involve trading the queen for The Rook
because if I keep this piece on the
board I have a greater chance of making
a complication and maybe even making
some kind of weird stalemate draw
okay
um
touching on all of this and that last
kind of thought experiment especially of
how to complicate a position I want to
look at a game that I played this was
actually the very first I think chess
YouTube video you can find me in uh was
for the a different class of the road
2000 but I went over a game I played
against uh women Grandmaster anashirovic
if you want to see that game in full
detail feel free to go find that video I
think it's called Alex mullering's 1400
Journey or something like that I'm not
going to go over the full game here but
I managed to secure a draw against her
in a simultaneous so she was playing
like 20 people so it wasn't that amazing
but the only reason I was able to I was
in a worse position and actually if we
look at this position she had black and
I had white
and already I'm down upon she is up upon
but I have created this nice past pawn
and I thought okay if I can continue to
avoid trades as best as possible and try
and make the position very complicated
then it increases the chances that both
of us make mistakes
and the only way I'm going to win
against the women's Grandmaster is if
she makes a mistake especially when I'm
already down material
so this is kind of the opposite right I
want to simplify the position when I
know if I trade everything off I'm going
to win I want to make it more
complicated when I think I'm not so sure
about that in the game I played the move
D6
she played Knight to C6
I played Rook to D5 attacking the pawn
she traded these pawns and then she
actually made a mistake here again the
position is sort of complicated I I'm
sort of close to promotion and she
played a very tricky move Knight to E7
with the idea that if I take
she can take my rook and this Rook on E3
is going to cover the promotion Square
so I'm not going to be able to promote
so something like this
um I can't promote because she'll take
it I can't defend the promotion Square
because one she'll just take the bishop
but also she could just choose to take
the pawn anyway
this is her idea attacking creating a
pin and putting me into a tough spot
uh unfortunately this didn't work out
for her because I uh I actually missed a
really strong move here I played move
rooked takes B5 which is still okay but
uh chess BS funny name in the chat said
uh Rook to D3
which is actually the best move it's
kind of really cool
um I'm attacking the bishop threatening
to just win this piece
and there's a lot of tricks here
um
so for example
if you take the Rook well now this Rook
is no longer defending this Square so I
can take the Knight
and threaten to promote
first I'm threatening to take I'm
threatening to promote this is a tough
spot right if you just jump in the way
then I take your Rook here
so I'm attacking both of your pieces
this is not a good spot to be in if you
are white so if if you don't take the
Rook um
then I'm just going to take your Bishop
right if you just back off I'm taking
your bishop and you're losing material
so either way I I'm doing really well
there so well spotted with Rook to D3
um but even missing that right I took
here
Night Moves I still try to keep it as
complex as possible having a pawn almost
ready to promote
Knight to E5 threatening to take my
Bishop and also attacking this pawn and
I found another move to make it really
complicated Rook to C5 attacking this
bishop
and I think my opponent kind of fell for
my idea thinking that I was a little
more of a beginner player she probably
assumed that
um okay if I take he's looking to just
make an exchange I'll take his Bishop
he'll take mine and then I can deal with
this Pawn maybe just double up the Rook
somehow and take this pawn and be okay
but my idea was not to win material
right I'm already down I'm playing for
complexity so after she takes my Bishop
I play the stunning move Rook to C8
pinning her Rook to the king she no
longer can take my piece or my Pawn
this is actually a really big problem so
she plays Bishop A5 defending
I play Knight takes G4 so I recapture my
uh she took my Bishop I took back her
Knight
she plays rookie seven and here once
again I kind of missed the winning move
it ended up being a draw
um the line in the game I played I
played uh Rook D1 defending the pawn
she called check I moved my king to F1
she played King f8 I brought my Rook up
to D6 with the idea that I am now
attacking her bishop and undermining the
defender of this Rook
uh she attacks my knight I move my
knight she played Ponto G6 and we agreed
to a draw in this position uh I had seen
in my head that if I take this bishop
um she can play takes here and I thought
this was going to be where I'm up a
little material but against a grand
master I didn't really want to play that
game
I could have easily won if I had found
this move though this is very very
strong
regardless that's a little behind a
little off topic
um the winning move here I'll give you
30 seconds or so if you want to try and
find it white to move and play better
than I did see if you can find the
winning move here it's actually
basically two moves
if you can find two moves then you can
win the game but it's really really
tough
while you're thinking about that I want
to give the kind of closing recap that
the whole idea of trading and Counting
material
is that we want to be able to properly
evaluate what our pieces are doing what
our opponent's pieces are doing and
whether or not it trade is in our favor
if our piece is doing more than our
opponent's piece or has the potential to
then we don't want to trade and vice
versa
that and the factors that play into that
are whether it's an open or closed
position how much space we have whether
we're attacking or defending whether we
have the ability to simplify into a
winning end game and so on and so forth
okay a few people have suggested some
moves and uh the best sequence is
actually to play Rook takes d8
forcing Bishop takes and then to play
the stunning move Knight E5
if you take my knight
then I will go here
threatening to take your Bishop with a
back rank Checkmate so you can't deal
with the pawn you're going to lose the
bishop whatever you do I take it and
then I just move my Rook out of the way
and you cannot stop me promoting to a
queen
and if you play anything else like F6
then I can still play immediately Rook
to C8 I am defending here so you can't
take I'll just take back and again
there's really nothing you can do takes
takes King out of the way and here you
can play a nice tactic like Rook to f8
drawing the king down in order to get a
queen
so kind of fun example at the end but
the the point for all of that is you
want to simplify into a winning end game
if you are ahead but if you were behind
then complicating the position avoiding
trades is generally going to be in your
favor
thank you so much for joining me uh for
this class hopefully it's been helpful
for you to think about counting material
evaluating positions and knowing when to
trade and when not to
and please stick around for our
grandmaster's choice lecture with
Grandmaster Igor novikov hope to see you
all again soon take care
[Music]
thank you